un baby sitting destinée aux familles
aux jeunes ni ni mon teint à la
recherche de garde d'enfants les
rencontres ont lieu à l'hôtel de ville
de montigny le bretonneux ce samedi 25
septembre le but faciliter la prise de
contact il n'y a aucune décision de
prise ce matin c'est simplement une
prise de contact les gens reprendront
contact par la suite et nous dans les
jours qui suivront nous continueront
d'accompagner les jeunes ou leurs fronts
rencontrées par exemple une éducatrice
de jeunes enfants qui pourra leur donner
des éléments sur la meilleure façon de
prendre en charge un enfant donc c'est
vraiment quelque chose à la fois d'un
service donné aux familles et donc d'une
aide aux jeunes mais aussi quelque chose
de formateurs pour les jeunes 56 baby
sitter âgés entre 16 et 25 ans se sont
rendus sur place pendant la journée la
plupart étaient des étudiants objectif
gagner de l'argent mais aussi de
l'expérience les faire de la garde
d'enfants bas pour avoir des petits
revenus pour les sorties des petites
choses comme ça pour la vie d'étudiant
et donc voilà c'est très pratique pour
les soirs les soirées de garder des
enfants j'aime bien de mon cockpit et
enfants et que aussi comme ça je peux
faire un petit peu d'argent de poche ça
peut être régulier par exemple juste une
soirée par semaine ou alors plusieurs
soirées si je suis dit reconnu par
semaine c'est pas choisi ouverte ou
alors occasionnels par exemple si les
parents veulent sortir un samedi soir ou
des choses comme ça je voudrais être
professeur plus tard donc c'est un
première approche avec les enfants puis
pour remplir ma semaine qui est un peu
vide est une quarantaine de familles
étaient présentes pour trouver la perle
rare on peut rencontrer beaucoup de
candidats et se faire une idée en fait
assez rapidement des gens qu'on souhaite
revoir par la suite et après engager
éventuellement moi je suis ravi c'est
vrai que les années précédentes j'ai
essayé de trouver comme ça on se dit
tiens on va aller au restaurant c'est
assez difficile de trouver quelqu'un
comme ça rapidement un livret contenant
les demandes des familles étaient
distribués aux jeunes en moyenne par an
et baby-sitters ont pu prendre une
dizaine de contacts